well so uh
the the first movie you you actually
made uh run was it run hide free hide
fight but you didn't make that with
daily wire correct they bought it yes so
this is a movie that uh you produced yes
and it's about a young woman and there's
a school shooting so that i i'm i'm
surprised you even got that made in the
current environment
to be bought by daily wire like how does
that happen our company paid for the
movie itself ourselves wow so we have
investors and they uh you know bet on me
and so what happened was we made the
movie we got you know great cast thomas
jane rona mitchell
isabelle may who's now the star of 1883
the
yellowstone prequel
and we went and made the movie by
ourselves totally independently
and right as i uh after i made it i was
in los angeles and i had a coffee with
ben shapiro
and i said i would talk to him about the
movie and he was very excited about it
and at the end of the coffee i said
let's make movies together he said
really he's i said yeah let's do it he
said well okay well we can help you in
the background you know but if you put
our name on it you're gonna get killed
i said are you crazy i'm gonna put your
name all over it you know i actually
want to ask a question about that so you
the run height fight was produced uh
beforehand and then they bought it so
then did they have to do press tours for
this with the actors and were the actors
hesitant about being involved with the
daily wire so like you said ben's
mentioned before he's like you got you
we he even before he asked said we'll do
it in the background because he just
assumes that they're not going to want
to be inv that you're not going to want
their name involved certainly
we had we had gotten a movie into venice
which is uh next to canon sundance the
most prestigious film festival in the
world
and we got a standing ovation and all
that kind of stuff but when we walked
out our text messages from our publicist
started coming in f you know zero out of
ten how dare you right personal politics
right all these things
and so i knew we were in big trouble
yeah so uh
by going with ben
the movie found its best by going with
daily wire the movie found its best home
that also meant that some of the actors
couldn't i couldn't ask them
to support the movie publicly beyond
their comfort zone
and some of them some of the actors
supported the movie some of the actors
supported the movie uh sort of privately
quietly and others just sort of tuned
out um
they're all
becoming big stars right now
and they all kind of love it right they
all kind of because they knew they were
in venice
when we all saw a great movie and then
standing ovation you standing ovation
wow the fact that they have to worry
about it at all is the most disturbing
part of all of this they no no bruh they
don't have to worry about it
if they don't yes if they if they were
if they had the uh you're you're both
right they they they do have to worry
about it but they don't have to they
right they shouldn't i'm making i'm
saying that as a point obviously they
worry for their careers i'm saying they
shouldn't for sure they they don't have
to if they choose not to these are not
by any stretch of the imagination
impoverished people
now that's right it's hard to ask
somebody to slash your income by by
large percentages
i mean look i get it um
i don't you know for a movie like shut
up i don't know i don't know if these
people are like a-lister celebrities
with worth millions of dollars but they
get paid probably substantially better
than say you know tradesmen or someone
working at starbucks i imagine they do
we
we
even on shut-in where we had the whole
cast in advance understanding who we
were making the movie with i mean we all
went to dinner before the movie started
shooting there was still an element of
right before the movie started coming
out and press time was on upon us
people started to get hesitant right
uh
in one case a publicist told one of the
actors involved in one of our movies uh
that we were cueing on right
and and and and and and that we and that
she would have been cancelled you know
this actress would have been cancelled
right away
now maybe that's true maybe that's not
our opinion is you suffer through 72
hours of bad tweets and then the world
moves on
right and you made the best movie you've
ever made in your career
isabella may is not the star of 1883
right now because taylor sheridan
watched katie and alexa or alexa and
katie on netflix he watched our movie
and she's great in it and now she's a
massive star
so
uh you know it's a tough thing i'll
never ask anyone to do anything they're
uncomfortable with but i will say and
we'll get into gina carano in a minute
gina we're working with someone who is
totally on board from day one oh man
that's great is fantastic that's just so
great that that's you know the fact that
she was so outspoken the entire time
while while on mandalorian and i'm i'm
following her on twitter and i'm just
like this is
you just gotta not worry and be yourself
and stand up for what you believe in and
when they canceled her she was just like
i'll find a way and she and ben and ben
appear in the daily wire we're like
we're going to make this work you got
nothing to worry about it's a great
story if you don't mind i'll tell you
absolutely it's so terrific so
i believe that
when when someone like gina has the guts
to do what she did
you have to
pray
that there are people like me and daily
wire ready to catch you and that's not
fully realized yet right it's not it's
not totally the infrastructure is not
all there yet we're we're building ours
but there needs to be more
so gina gets cancelled on a wednesday
night at 10 pm
i text jeremy boring the ceo of
dailywire at 10.05
and he texts me right back ben and i
were just texting about this i said dude
keep your phone on tomorrow morning i'm
going to call you is going to move very
fast just please keep your phone on
so
i reached out to gina's agent who i used
to work for the agent said yeah we're
dropping her i said oh
i said oh it's terrible i said well at
least give me her manager's phone number
so i reached out to the manager i'd
known him uh from my la days barely
right can you say which agency this was
was it a big uta united talent agency
right yeah they're they're top three for
sure i'm not a fan huge agency uh the
same agent by the way it still
represents james franco who by the way
i'd work with in a second love him but
yes james plus james franco is more
cancelled than gina carano yet because
one gets dropped the film school stuff
about the intimacy of course yeah you
know
james come so
you know
it it it's it's such a such a joke right
so i reach out to the manager who i'd
known back in l.a
say hey uh let's get on the phone so we
spoke immediately he's like oh okay it's
like we're kind of just you know reeling
from all this we were gonna sort of take
a step back and like you know we're
getting calls from megyn kelly and
hannity and all the stuff i said no no
two things one
say no to all of it number two
you have to move now you have to trust
me i'm your guardian angel i'm showing
up daily wire and and we are going to do
this let's go so the next morning
we got gina on the phone with uh
ben himself
we got jeremy and i on the phone with
the manager
we banged out a deal that day dallas is
in the middle of a snow storm where i
live
uh
and then friday morning we announced it
on deadline hollywood wow that we
did a movie deal with her and that
exploded more than the original
announcement
so this
is how you fight you were right about
moving fast fast that's boosted morale
by monday the the story is passed it's
it nobody cares it's that fast so we had
to she got fired when's wednesday night
10 p.m
by 10 a.m friday morning the
announcement and she'd had us man
we gotta we gotta get tim cass films
going oh we have to yeah when you're
talking about we're we're growing
decentralizing or basically a new
hollywood a parallel system how do you
envision that because i wonder hollywood
centralized that was kind of the point
of it was there's all these big walled
boom stage sound stages and stuff so do
you want to put them all over the place
well we're all in nashville what do you
think definitely it has to grow an
ecosystem almost taking the role of an
old hollywood studio system so we would
have multiple screenwriters uh you know
uh that we would pay full salaries to
right they can make more money that way
anyway full benefits all this kind of
real jobs writing and directing movies
do you think do you think we need to
build like localized sound stages
absolutely nashville has a few and we've
used them and they're pretty good
they've got uh you know some some really
nice ones but they still don't have one
that's competitive with atlanta or
albuquerque yet
okay what's that going to run we talk
about that stuff off air i guess yeah
500 million whoa
okay
yeah but uh full ecosystem i mean that's
netflix money so what our what our move
right now is
baby steps right
i came my my sort of emotional gift to
daily wire in many ways is that i'm
gonna work on these movies as if my life
depends on them right
because they can't be bad if they're bad
we will get shunned mocked
all this kind of stuff they're still
going to attack us and they are there's
some amazing articles that came out the
last few days about us
but like you know trying to poo poo the
movies but these articles exist because
they're scared who cares about them i
love it this is what this is what i'm
saying if there's somebody who's like
ghostbusters 2016 was a great
accomplishment by all means go watch
ghostbusters 2016. enjoy it i'm very
happy for you i'm gonna go watch run
hide fight or shut in and enjoy myself
and if you want that hollywood you can
do whatever you want but but i'm saying
if they keep going down this path i
think it's very obvious that their
system is going to crumble we the the
the gentleman we had on the other day
steven even mentioned that when
institutions start getting woke they
start falling apart right and he's a guy
who has a very establishment world view
on things very critical of the far right
as you would call it but even he
recognizes media companies are moving
left and once they do it starts just
crumbling
so if hollywood wants to get woke and go
broke by all means i'm not going to
complain about it oh let him if i if if
my neighbor wants to go swimming with
alligators i'm going to be like i will
advise against it but far be it for me
to tell you what risks you can't take
now we'll go over here we'll make some
good movies and have some fun and make
jokes and not have to worry about being
canceled every two seconds and then i
think 10 years from now the work you're
doing the work bench appear on the daily
wire is doing is planting a tree whose
shade you will actually get to sit
beneath and so will your children that
is the hope that is the entire hope that
is what this is all about it's to it's
to create infrastructure and ecosystem
for people who are willing to take risks
and fight the system knowing they can do
do that get canceled and come over here
and work with us it's also
really important that we make great
movies so this is sustainable it has to
make money
right so we're making movies that are
small budget big idea little box on
purpose but we're growing quickly i mean
the budgets are already moving up we're
going to get into series all these kind
of things so
it's game on well it's like it's going
to take trailblazers in the writing in
the production part too because like you
said like gina walks away uh as an actor
those same people who have been told
that they have to live within the
hollywood ecosystem are going to have to
walk away and know and feel strongly
enough about the work they create that
they believe that that uh that that
script that that show can stand on its
own two legs no matter where it's put
out not through the perceived legitimacy
of hollywood but through any form of
media that it can come out through and
the story uh is what elevates it not the
uh the deadlines not the av clubs in the
establishment press media that make
these things seem like they're better
than they are the you know
yeah i think we got to utilize piracy
game of thrones was like one of the most
pirated shows of all time and it was
also one of the most popular i think
those that's not a coincidence
piracy is a tricky one um uh when you're
in a transactional business
vod movies or even theatrical you're so
ins you're so reliant on that purchase
of that movie
when you're in the streaming world the
money's coming in and it's for a bunch
of stuff right in daily wires case
there's the political
uh folks that are you know political
members uh they're they're watching the
podcast and the political uh content
there's folks who are simply fans of ben
or candace owens for example and then
there's the people who are who love the
movies and they're all going into one
revenue stream and it's really working
from a financial perspective so the
company is super healthy it's run like a
real fortune whatever company
a fortune you know however many numbers
company and it's terrific and you walk
in
and you're you cannot believe
the feeling
of being surrounded by all of these
people who you know if they don't share
your exact same values they're civically
aligned they have the same goal which is
not to be the other side do you think
there's a value at running it at a loss
like selling on the room for 99 cents uh
pop and taking like our version 70 laws
our version of that has been opening
night youtubes so we play the movies on
youtube one night only
uh for the first 20 you know for the
first two hours it's only available two
hours in fact if you start at 15 minutes
late you're gonna have to go watch the
the 15 minutes on daily wires uh
you know on their site is there a way
that they're going to figure this out
financially like when we look at like we
we break down box offices it's already
cash flow positive okay but like we
break down box offices so when a studio
invests 100 million dollars they put 1.5
times that into marketing uh then they
have to look at their return on
investment for what they make at the box
office how are they going to be figuring
those numbers out when it comes to
streaming it's actually worse than that
you got to add in foreign sales you've
got to add and they only take 60 of the
box office even less if it's in china
the value of who your star is things
like that
all of those pressure points on making a
great movie go out the window so this is
as close as you can get to 1969 easy
rider as i could possibly imagine i mean
it is the easy writer most people don't
know this but easy rider and five easy
pieces and the last picture show
and some of these other great movies
were all produced by these three guys
uh uh sbs and there's a great criterion
collection about their works and these
guys set up their own shop they had
their own deal with pair uh with the
columbia tri-star at the time
and they made these great movies that's
all we're doing here we're just creating
sort of the most creatively unfiltered
version of hollywood absolutely possible
today
i would like to think that uh once the
work starts coming out more frequently
and people can see that what they're
producing is not conservative media per
se it's just good media that as culture
turns people come with it and it becomes
less stigmatized yeah and and certainly
one day we'll be uh accused of making a
truly conservative movie like like like
i'd love to make a comedy called kamala
exclamation point you know like uh yeah
maybe a question mark
i mean
come on i call it hbo films in reverse
right i would love i would love to do
that at some point but not right now but
it's going to get labeled that way
that's interesting you have to not care
that the like i said the deadlines the
av clubs all these websites the shield
media are going to call it that just
like they label religious films you know
the way they sing but paint all
religious films with the same brush well
you know there was a period where i
cared
you know maybe a few years ago worried
about
mainstream press their reactions and
like i was saying it's because i felt
like we were part of one system together
right and i didn't want them i don't
want my neighbor to feel to think bad
things about me that don't represent me
then i started to realize eventually
like these people aren't our neighbors
anymore yeah and it's scary it's
unfortunate but uh i'm not interested in
trying to convince people who hate me
and refuse to listen when i try to be
nice to them yeah i'm actually when when
i've approached many of these people be
it on the ground in portland at protests
or on facebook and i'm nice to them and
their response is i literally don't care
what you have to say f you you fascist
i'm like
okay then then i'm gonna go do my thing
over there you no longer factor in so
when these media outlets say whatever
they want don't care we're gonna build
our thing we're gonna do a good job of
it and guess what's gonna happen like i
said five ten years
people are going to be knocking down the
door desperate to get a role with daily
wire productions with your company and
i'll tell you this too
look at rumble right now i advise people
when they're like how do i want to make
a show i want to do youtube videos no no
you want to do rumble videos because
youtube has pulled up the ladder behind
everybody else you're getting banned you
don't know what you can or can't say
live streamers get too popular too fast
they take you down start on rumble
you've got more market opportunity this
means in la there's going to be writers
there's going to be production
assistance producers smaller staff aps
whatever and they're going to say i
would rather move to nashville because i
know there's a great opportunity with
daily wire and the stuff they're
producing and it's freeing but more
importantly the market opportunity
hollywood is is such a monolith it's so
hard to break in you hear all these
stories about people sending a pizza
into producers when they open it there's
a there's a headshot don't even worry
about there's a real opportunity now
with what you guys are doing over at
daily wire and your productions so why
bother with trying to climb an ivory
tower when you can go knock on the front
door of people who said we want to do
great stuff and we want to make make
something new here's your opportunity
you were telling us the story beforehand
about tom cruise negotiating his own
contract for risky business okay can you
explain that sorry because i want to
pull back to that yeah there was a
fantastic article on daily mail today uh
interviewing tom cruise's first manager
from when he was 18 to 22 or 3.
and uh tom cruise when he when he was
engaging on risky business
sent an email uh sorry sent a a a letter
uh to his agent at caa
telling her what to counter in the
negotiation
the the fee down to the size of the
trailer everything involved and it was
just fascinating and it just goes to
show you what a movie star truly is and
so the the modern day business savvy
actors writers directors are going to
start see the tides turning see things
shift and they're going to see that
nashville is just as a
as a much of a opportunity for them as
it would be to go straight to california
and you would hope that in there there's
going to be some script a couple of
scripts here and there they're going to
be so good and they're going to stand
out so well that it will be that initial
cultural shift that uh that touchstone
that pushes things to me you know to
bring it
back to back this way absolutely and and
and those floodgates have have
flung open right i'm getting a phone
call almost every day now from an actor
a director a writer
major major players people who have show
run that's the head producer on a tv
show head writer of the some of the
biggest tv shows
just saying i'm so sick of this like
please like what's going on there what
are you doing and then also
i think we've become
very inspirational to a younger
generation of filmmakers
i have this rule i i answer every email
so send me an email dallas bonfire
legend dot com i will i will write you
back
and you know i try to respond to every
single email quickly sometimes it takes
me a few days but
i want i want to to encourage these
filmmakers these young people who who
understand culture at that generation
better than i do to create create create
and hopefully they can bring me the
right i guess we need to start building
tutorials of how to use sound equipment
and lighting equipment
oh that's all over youtube for sure good
have you looked into starting a new
union i'm kind of fed up with sag i was
thinking about a web actors guild like
wag or something
you could decide not to screw people
over but also that you don't have to pay
them
sure 1400 a day or whatever the the the
uh the unions are are
sort of separated into the crew and then
what we call above the line actors
writers and directors those three have
their own guilds sag wga dga and then
the crew is under iatsi
and it's a really challenging
relationship for low-budget independent
producers to work with these unions they
have for the most part a reason to exist
for the netflix's of the world when it
comes to a million dollar movie it's
very hard to engage with them what i
think the trick is
is if if we're going to sort of go
further out into the woods
uh on these movies and and and and
really make them on our own we have to
be good stewards right we have to pay
people fairly we have to provide
opportunities the other thing is
like especially with the stunt actors
their insurance is through sag
so if they get hurt doing a stunt and if
you've seen any of my movies there are
tons of stunts in every one of them
someone dies in every movie and and it's
like
you know if if if these people get hurt
they need the they need the the
insurance to to protect their families
and still no oscar for stunts can we set
up oh there should be that's a good
point dude
best part of movies continue in today's
day and age where stunts make up such a
huge percentage of the tentpole films
that we see and they get no recognition
for it whatsoever oh brilliant
great yeah you heard that's a great idea
instead why don't we create our own
oscars
stunts will be the last the last let's
do it remember the wiries they did like
the the what was the the youtube video
award ceremonies they started doing yeah
and then like vidcon and all that let's
just start like a new in nashville
absolutely not even i'm not even you
know you know what we do need so uh are
you familiar with vidcon yeah
there are there are there was a year
where a bunch of youtubers with big
followings
showed up because their political
commentary cultural commentary and
they're shunned but i'll tell you my
story i actually uh
had a big talent agency reach out to
vidcon this was back when i was working
for disney when at the abc company and
they're like hey tim poole is a
streaming journalist we'd love to get
him involved and they said nope don't
care don't won't do it they end up doing
journalism panels with people who aren't
journalists and have no followings and
so i'm just like this is an industry
insider game if you're a friend of the
people who run it they'll claim you're a
journalist and put you on a panel for
which you have no expertise and have you
talked to a bunch of people it's just
trash
so you know what
we do need our own multimedia video
social media conference
that
actually talks about merit because
that's what that's what their whole
system is about authoritarianism the the
the woke multicultural democracy is a
religious hierarchy if you are part of
the party you get privileged you'll be
cool if the crowd talks if the crowd
decides who gets to go speak at it but
then you've got to avoid popularity
contests so there's going to be there
should be some sort of calculation that
doesn't work because you need uh you
need
if the people all knew who say you were
then why would they need to see you go
speak if they know who you are because
they've heard you speak the the issue is
if we're doing a big event it's to
introduce people to um experts in
certain fields and certain industries to
tell them about what's going on how you
know here's what you should learn here's
what here's the information i can give
you the problem with vidcon is they have
like you know they bring on this woman
who has like a thousand twitter
followers who doesn't really work in
journalism and then they have her speak
to an audience of people as an expert
i'm like
why don't you actually just reach out to
people who are experts and invite them
to come so that is
the woke authoritarianism if you are a
part of the cult they'll just put you in
a privileged position and claim you're
an expert makes no sense but it's
exactly what these regimes have done in
the past people who aren't farmers are
given farms
we need meritocracy someone who's got
proven skills who's worked in the
industry will be invited to come speak
and share their knowledge the way it
used to be remember they hate
meritocracy right they hate the idea of
meritocracy well exactly you you hit on
it though because it used to be a
situation where we were all
in a respectful relationship with each
other and the other sides and that is
gone
these people hate you
i say that all smile on your face these
people hollywood hates you
i'm not talking about you i'm talking
about you and
everyone who doesn't
just you know sort of just just i i what
to their absolute religion just to edit
that i think they hate everyone
that's the elite part
of themselves but here's everything
around them but here's where it gets
weirder i get also i get phone calls
from my friends who are still inside the
system trapped right and they're having
to go to their you know sessions and
their
biases trainings and things like that
and it is that they they have to play
ball
because they're getting paid so much
money that to lose that salary right
it's the it's the freedom scale so the
money holds them hostage absolutely
absolutely and and and that's the only
way they can get a movie made they don't
they don't know how to come out and and
risk it all and all this kind of stuff
but they're starting to crack a little
bit right it's it's exciting right it's
exciting to see it what you guys are
doing is going to create a position
where hollywood will be forced to to to
mingle yeah to cross over you're
and i'm like daily wire gotta carry
always film that is that is impressive
he's fantastic
sooner or later hollywood's gonna say
if people are finding opportunity right
with this other new emerging you know
film industry
we are going to we're not going to be
competitive if we put constraints on
them that the daily wire guys don't so
if the issue is right now
someone can choose to do a movie with
you guys and your position is we'll
always work with you and hollywood
threatens them they're going to say you
know maybe i just go where it's easier
and less stressful hollywood will be
forced to be like no no no no we won't
we won't blacklist you we need your
talent too that's that's the market
competition you guys are bringing that's
what we need to see when i was in
hollywood
i worked with folks on the left and
folks on the right tons of them right
the folks on the right never had an
issue working with folks on the left
the reverse was so painful it was just
just constant complaining and this and
that and everything was a problem you
know i i remember coming in uh to work
one day after trump was elected
and half the office was crying right and
i just i i thought to myself oh my gosh
something it like i don't understand
this right i don't even identify with
with this behavior
and and and so then you know it took me
a little while to catch up to
uh where i was supposed to be which is
you know my optimized version now which
is hopefully you know making movies of
the daily wire for a decade plus i'd
love to you know i'm obviously
considering moving to nashville and and
and being a really big even a bigger
part of it than i am now but i'm having
a blast and and it's it's so
important uh to do this now because i
didn't i didn't i didn't grow up as a 13
year old uh
wanting to
run you know
produce independent movies that i'm
producing now i thought i was gonna be
running paramount
i thought i was gonna be the president
of production of paramount like my idol
robert evans kid stays in the picture
well you you you technically will be
yeah it just won't be called paramount
that's great it will be a major studio
producing some of the biggest films in
the world and it'll be called something
i thought the same thing i was like i'm
going to be brad pitt and then i got
just that sexuality gross to me and i
was like i've got to bail on this ian
was in this but i'm still commercial we
can do it yeah we can make we can become
the biggest thing on earth that's not
the way it seemed thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8pm and don't forget
to smash that like button subscribe to
this channel and if you want more
unfiltered and uncensored content with
all of these guests go to timcast.com
and become a member all of these guests
you know and love in exclusive segments
on our website where we are unrestricted
in what we talk about so you'll
definitely not want to miss it thanks
for hanging out we'll see you all next
time